you've worked with Shakira the one half
should Kelly amazing Super Bowl halftime
show Shakira
you worked with Shakira I worked with
Shakira on Wizards of Waverly Place and
the premise was that people go uncle
Kelbo yeah I'm the show Wizards away
because I was on like a half dozen times
and one episode it was shown that I was
Shakira
there's my special powers I would go
live life with Shakira she was actually
in the episode oh so you're actually
what you you become Shakira you aren't
you here we go back and forth yeah but
when we go back and forth I also wore
some Shakira style outfits which is a
big bowling wrong thing by the way a
doll and you hang out so I'm with her
okay so this one cat suit I had to wear
with like holes on the side yeah it was
just wrong on so many levels and I'm
wearing a robe because you got to match
her look she's wearing it and you gotta
wear the same by the way she in it yeah
perfection yeah me in it what yeah so
Shakira says let me I'm wearing a rope
she goes let me see I go No Selena Gomez
walks up and go what are you guys
talking about she does he won't let me
see you know what he and I go okay they
kept them bothering me so we went
backstage I'm backstage with Shakira and
Selena Gomez and I did something I've
never done before since I opened my robe
like this and I'm wearing the cat suit
yeah anyone looking thinks there's a
pervert yes look at the side is going
what's going on yeah yeah what is going
on yes but they were begging me and then
they both burst out laughing which is
appropriate right but then Shakira when
she hangs out she dances like she dances
like just hanging out she'll do her
things if she's if Shakira's at an ATM
she's gyrating and she's in the mood
if she's in the mood anywhere she does
it so I was a huge fan of Shakira's even
though I never heard her music night
Comfort they true and I told Selena and
I go I got a crush on her I love her you
know so she starts doing this stuff now
I'm wearing this little sheer thing and
I'm afraid I'm gonna get a boner because
she's doing this bouncy thing and I keep
saying you got to stop please stop your
dance because what does some music came
on she's just doing this all over and
I'm a foot away from Shakira doing that
oh my god so I close my row boner we ran
away before you became excited in any
way in one particular way yeah well we
all know what's gone Selena Gomez who at
the time was a teen it wasn't she was a
minor but nonetheless I had that you
know I mentioned earlier I wasn't sure
that this episode what air this will not
air I'm getting an erection don't worry
she's 18 no but the point is she knows
that I'm like into Shakira
so he's laughing her ass off 18
year-olds know about boners but Iran
Iran to be appropriate I think you did
the right thing I think the man running
with an erection is always
anytime I get an erection I just take
off I lost my virginity Oh to a heckler
when I was 20 in a little you lost your
virginity and in a stand-up club to a
heckler not in a club but she had
heckled me earlier in the evening later
in the evening it was that South Beach
she went she apologized a bridge came up
to me like I don't really want to talk
to you and then she kissed me and I was
like wow look at that
she went running on the beach ripping
off her clothes yelling follow me so I
followed her to a lifeguard stand and
yeah that's how I lost my virginity wait
a minute that's an amazing story you
your first the first person you're with
heckled you yes what is that I'm a true
comedian this yes I am I am a comedian I
knew I wanted to be when I was 8 years
old I didn't know I'd lose it to a
heckler but very fitting yeah when crowd
work yeah when we were having sex there
was no heckling yeah and I will say yeah
that's an incredible story yeah but the
point being is when you said would you
run right over a boner so high
I kicked it I had fold I'm a Jewish boy
I folded my clothes she's naked I take
up my clothes so I kicked my stuff off
the lifeguard stand
during the festival and I run downstairs
naked run naked with the festival and
I'm there and there's a guy like about
to steal my clothes and I'm naked I go
you get away so weird being yet you're
about to thieve and a naked guy yeah
with a boner yeah it's going hey man
yeah you know you don't have to point I
got my clothes together I went back in
the lab the stand to go back at it and I
folded my clothes again no you're right
your your tidy your tidy little Jewish
boy yeah now I'm a big Jewish man and I
will fold my clothes as I see fit